[Música]
hay muchas aristas en el conflicto entre
Rusia y Ucrania dónde occidente toma
cada vez más protagonismo hoy nos
enfocamos en las sanciones el presidente
estadounidense yo baidan anunció
represalias que incluyan bloqueos
totales al banco militar Ruso y el banco
Estatal que encargan del apoyo del
desarrollo de la economía y gestionar la
deuda del Estado además los fondos de
pensiones vayan Considero que las
decisiones de Putin son el inicio de una
invasión Rusia Ucrania vista por la casa
blanca como una flagrante al derecho
internacional por su parte la Unión
Europea anunció que sancionará a los 351
diputados de la Uma rusa que votaron a
favor de reconocer Dueñas y logans como
repúblicas independientes así como 27
ciudadanos rusos Y por último Reino
Unido también se unió a todas estas
medidas
que cualquier ciudadano británico y
entidades dentro del reino tengan
cualquier negocio con ellos para ello
Entonces quiero saludar en este momento
a nuestro primer invitado el día el ese
Sebastián vigliero el profesor de
relaciones internacionales de la
Universidad de Buenos Aires analiza
internacional miembro consejero del
Consejo argentino para las relaciones
internacionales gracias a profesor por
estar con nosotros en directo América de
Francia 24 le pregunto qué tanto impacto
tendrán esta primera ronda de sanciones
a Rusia hay quienes dicen que realmente
no son efectivas le pregunto Entonces si
les afecta realmente sirven estas
sanciones
Qué tal Buen día las sanciones siempre
me afecta afectan y son más duras
las sanciones impuestas tras la invasión
de crimea Y eso que no se llegó todavía
una dureza máxima como hacer la
aplicación de la suspensión de la red
internacional o trasnacional del sistema
financiero en que involucra todos los
países eso todavía no no se tocó pero
las sanciones abordan cuestiones que
tienen que ver con medidas de tinte
político con medida de tinte bueno
financiero y comercial el político
directamente basado en el derecho
internacional claramente occidente
entiende que esto es una violación la
grande por parte de Rusia
intenta sancionar del punto de vista
financiero y político actual a todos
aquellos personajes involucrados que
hayan votado medidas en favor de la de
la de la invasión
desde el punto de vista comercial
también se va a hacer sentir ya vemos
que el tema del gas es importante
Alemania acaba de anunciar la suspensión
de la activación de norfton 2
también se acaban de anunciar medidas
vinculadas a los suspensión de las
actividades bancarias algunas entidades
privadas y públicas rusas no van a poder
operar y también es importante y
novedoso que Rusia no va a poder tomar
deuda o va a estar muy restringida de
tomar deuda en el ámbito internacional
Eso sí es grave y puede afectar mucho
las sanciones
querían dar un poco a lo que dijo no la
decisión de Alemania de parar el inicio
del funcionamiento de ese gasoducto
hablamos el no es un dos Qué estaría
perdiendo Rusia con una cancelación de
este proyecto y también le quiero
preguntar si no es un arma de doble filo
para Alemania y Europa dependiente del
gas ruso
en realidad Cuando cuando usted menciona
armas de doble filo es complicado para
todos la gran interdependencia que hay
en pleno proceso de globalización Siglo
XXI es inusitado que se produzca esto es
como decir nos vamos a aislar y vamos a
suspender todas las relaciones
económicas políticas y sociales en el
mundo hoy es imposible para un país
hacer eso ahora con el tema de Alemania
es complicado porque
nostrin 2
le asegura un volumen
Millonario
denosamente de provisión a cambio de
prohibición de btu a la empresa gaspron
rusa
Y esto es muy importante para el erario
ruso ahora qué ocurre acá evidentemente
suministro se va a empezar a cortar o se
va a haber limitado Europa va a tratar
de buscar algunas alternativas que no es
lo conveniente
y el precio del gas va a subir Ya esta
historia la conocemos en el 2006 ocurrió
que a raíz de algunas diferencias entre
Ucrania y Rusia Rusia suspende no
queriendo suspende
el traspaso de gas hacia Europa y ahí sí
intervino la otan y terminaron reuniones
de alto nivel es un problema pero en
este caso es una complicación para Rusia
y para Europa uno porque demanda Europa
y el otro porque está vendiendo y
necesita
hacerse de más con las restricciones que
hay desde el 2014 hacerse de ingreso no
olvidemos que el 70% del ingreso ruso
vía comercio exterior tiene que ver con
la energía o con los hidrocarburos
entonces Este es un tema que se las trae
y la alternativa china todavía a partir
del año 2014 para Rusia no está muy
configurada es importante pero no está
muy configurado claro ahora profesor
entonces con todas estas sanciones puede
cambiar algo de la postura del
presidente ruso Vladimir Putin ya
sabiendo que sí realmente afecta a su
economía sus relaciones diplomáticas y
pues todo lo que estábamos conversando
yo creo que desde el vamos Rusia no
quiero que digamos apuntar únicamente a
la figura de Putin yo creo que apuntó a
su a lo que puede como objetivo de
máxima y lo que puede de mínimo
sopesó para mi gusto
qué podría qué podía hacer y que no qué
podía hacer era tomar posición en el
este de Ucrania que ya lo viene
haciéndose mucho tiempo simplemente que
habría un costo político que ya lo
conoce también porque luego en el 2008
cuando Rusia invadió Georgia por 5 días
y se quedó después con con dos
provincias con una serie de regiones yo
creo que sospecó eso habría costo Sí por
supuesto el costo de la del de la
crítica hacia la uni lateralidad de la
fuerza así el costo de la crítica de
parte de Ucrania Sí pero también abrazo
pesado ganancias que Buscar un objetivo
ulterior Qué es producto del avance
sistemático de la otan hacia el este y
de tratar de forjar y tejer vínculos
comerciales económicos financieros con
países vecinos de Rusia es un tema ya
político ideológico y hasta se diríamos
filosófico en Rusia se sienta amenaza
entonces frente a esto
Rusia seguramente abrazo pesado el
objetivo es sentar a la mesa los países
de la otan para discutir algo que ahí sí
para mí es medio imposible que es
retrotraer el el digamos El Avance de la
otan hacia los países del este de Europa
no ahora profesor muy rápidamente porque
no quiero que se me quede por fuera algo
muy importante ustedes estaba
mencionando y es la posibilidad de
retirar a Rusia de sistema financiero
swit del lenguaje común para todas estas
transacciones internacionales que
impacto tenía esto tendría esto para la
economía rusa y también para la global
yo diría total se corta automáticamente
todas las transacciones esto es como en
un país cortar el sistema no financiero
sino el sistema Por donde se hace la
compraventa de moneda por ejemplo que
regula por los bancos centrales bueno
Imagínese a nivel internacional es como
romper con todas las reglas basilea
prácticamente es aislarse esto es aislar
un país Entonces no creo que se llegue a
eso creo que hay otra forma que tiene
accidente y otros países de sancionar y
general un Cos